Monday morning Monday much from sold-out
shows in Calgary lots of fun
your Instagram makes a difference yeah
let's not are you the worst marker in
the world by that I mean rug was like
was that really your crowd I was like
there are four people in the audience I
was making a joke goddamnit 15 texts
that what happened to Brian and Calgary
I'm like not sold ie I sold out all my
shows and Thank You Calgary you know
it'd been funny if you would have posted
a video of the sold-out shows yeah and
then now cuz we don't assume it's sold
out cuz you don't pull anything yeah all
you did is post with four people in the
crowd well I saw that I thought it was
so ridiculous that they were gonna come
on you know but it wasn't but there
wasn't for there was like kind of
episode yeah there yeah but if you know
by the way the staff is really
enthusiastic so yeah look like ya know
wow I appreciate the effort Brent's
showing you but I've social media I
wouldn't post about myself though it's
all good Oh Seth Rogen was that wasn't
really your crowd ago no I sold out you
guys silly goose I was like honk honk
yeah yeah yeah I'm writing off about
three hours of sleep a night for four
days in a row I were laughing it bit you
know boys little uh here's pneumonia
weather pneumonia now how does that feel
I don't know I like start off as a
confidence gradually gets worse worse
and worse and then we have to take into
Urgent Care yesterday but he just
thought he has that horrible cough so
then you just I mean yeah I'll sleep I
know it's like it's like going through
[ __ ] training camp as a parent I mean
just I remember I just remember that
call for there they'd be like oh my god
I know it's weird how your kids and I
well you think a straight trip we can't
do much it's like a straight training
camp I mean two hours sleep it's like
you're trying to become the shittiest
Navy SEAL in the world like I'm rolling
off about three hours sleep a lot of
food yeah pretty stressed out well you
know what I ate [ __ ] e buds training
camp oh you wouldn't problems you in the
other dude yeah you wouldn't call me
sensitive right I mean I'm not a very
sensitive you know like if your wife is
a game you know Brian's actual still
serial killer he's killed like thirty
people like makes it make sense he's
yeah
but the one thing I can't take is uh I
saw my my daughter get a shot she had to
take it and she started to cry I can't
watch it dude I think my wife yesterday
my wife has to be there that's why I
can't do it you know why don't cuz I and
I would imagine when you're both your
kids when they were younger you officer
you were working so your wife was always
at the doctor put so you're not it's not
it's not familiar to you right same with
me yesterday would take Tiger urgent
care and they gave him some antibiotics
I'd do by shot I'm like when they
they're like oh we can give this world
stuff and we need give them a shot cuz
it is you know is pneumonia it's pretty
serious let's give him this and it knock
it out for gets worse mom shot he's like
yeah which duchamp like shot huh I hate
shot and then the guy goes his Tigers
spin I mean he hates the doctor laughs
just been crying
he's like exhaust all these tears and
the guy looked at me funny start from
Stanford us it can't get any worse I
mean it's it's written rock fair man I
go it's been rough as in he goes yeah
yeah it's been rough so the shots gonna
help him kid getting worse what does he
what does he mean it's been was it just
cuz Tigers he's been tonight all right
she tried doing x-rays and we did four
of them finally in the fifth when they
got it right like he's [ __ ] strong
and me trying to hold him down was a
nightmare yeah nightmares
yeah he's Lex man be well cuz I'm now
that his has his his haircut yeah so
what so his long hair softened his edges
you've got a short haircut right now
you're talking about a square-jawed Navy
SEAL I mean he's a little Navy SEAL he
couldn't be more jacked already these
doctors and I could not hold him death
so then he's like this shot we had to
Islamic know dies it I'm sure you've had
a million shots like yeah dude never get
fun dude I thought I like and it's lefse
about their faults just my instincts I
want to hit the doctor of course you
want to hit it so hard to see your
little boy and pick a beast was a super
beast man I can't and I guess it's just
out well this morning we woke up at 4:30
a.m. and he's like Papa that's every
morning and I go and get him 4:30 like
4:30 brilliant so I bring him down and
then
wants to watch we watch a show then we
go on our walk you want to go on a walk
first
like David 4:30 in the morning Wow Wow
but you're a beast I'm impressed hard
though isn't it it's hard to know I
don't mind it though I'm all right I'm
all right
I'm good I'm sure to catch up and what
do you need you need six or seven or
eight hours I like it out I'm good eight
if I don't know if I'm not doing a set
at night and then I'm I'm in bed by like
nine ish yeah because you guys are moms
you work out you need your you need your
everybody needs to sleep but yeah yeah
everyone needs to sleep
yeah I always find it fascinating people
and there's a few people out there it's
like less than two percent of the
population ride off for hours right but
then you know the rock thoughts about
you see these like P Diddy boys there
are liars that's what I think you know
we want oh oh cuz they're liars well
here's my flood here's my theory on that
I agree with you I think they're either
a lying uh-huh it's very strange and be
there on some [ __ ] mmm both both the
liars and they're on some [ __ ] yeah dude
oh my god you know Harper sent known for
my work ethic I like to work hard you
know but I'm like God I mean I tried
doing that man after about three four
days get sick and die get some yeah you
get sick I got bird flu now yeah bird
flu [ __ ] yes a bird flu
I am I tried to do that well I decided I
was reading on this [ __ ] mind over
matter [ __ ] in college and I was
reading about like how you know it's all
about basically your mind and your will
and sleep yeah I was trying to do the
four hour a night thing and then
training and stuff and I would work out
through the fatigue I got I almost died
yeah it was done I got a sore throat
that turned into a cold that lasted well
I just got over it last week
Yoga straight die from no sleep oh yes
you will straight up dime it wreaks
havoc on your immune system orrible yeah
or you can't do it that was my dad tried
doing it you know what my dad was doing
these books and you know I think my dad
was especially when I was young as like
I think eight or nine and he was trying
to get his business going so he's
working relentless hours and he was
reading some book where this guy he
wouldn't sleep full eight hours she'd
take naps throughout the 24 hours it's
my dad's like oh I'll get more work done
I'll take a nap every I forget what does
not I'll tell you what it was well it is
start doing that after two days my that
was a song yeah so there's there's a way
to do it actually that you can do they
say and this is from a guy Russell
Foster who's this sleep expert and
Oxford University and there's a way to
do this where you can actually if you do
it really strictly you can last like a
month and get stuff done so what you do
is you stay awake for hours you take
exactly a 20-minute nap no more than
that for hours 20 minutes for hours 20
minutes and you can't do any more if you
sleep any more than that you get into a
different cycle yeah and then there are
dietary things we involved yeah good
luck by the way good luck I'm gonna be a
robot you better be a robot but there is
a dose two naps this is just not the way
we're supposed to do function that when
you'd grind man but up but also the the
NAP thing it's just not like you need
sleep you need to shut off your body
rejuvenate and get everything and
refocus like yeah sleep is one big
percent I I did and there's this weird
thing in our culture where sleep is a
weakness yeah and if you're in a
relationship when you have a kid there's
a whole my wife I have to give it up she
can she can grind for a while but I
don't think she uses as much energy
during the day as I do she's not as
kinetic as I am you know different
people are very creative with the kids
typically and it hurt jobs the day is
very tiring by the way though she's
always about this fall asleep at 9:00
she goes to bed so oh yeah and I'm the
lake so it just depends different
animals we all need it eight hours man
seven and a half eight hours yeah those
pee I hope yeah I mean I'm sure there's
some people in need like four hours but
their fares are at a high level god I
feel like they're lying I don't some
good drugs and I want in yeah because
I've talked to I've talked to um SEAL
team guys and those guys and you know
cuz I - they don't get enough sleep and
to a man everyone I'm was like first of
all I need sleep second of all take
drugs well they take drugs you stay
awake oh that's what your provincial or
you know different kinds of speed
compounds whatever it might be that's
that's what you do if you're a fighter
pilot you take drugs to run your rolling
told me about if you order it's called
mow a vigil for vigil yes yeah where
it's like laser focus yeah and like you
just you take one of those you're up for
yeah yep it has an effect like caffeine
but a little bit
yeah and but but sighs so I looked it up
so I supposed to be bad for either it
depends the only thing about sleep is
that they are now finding that your
brain gets gummed up so like your brain
develops for lack of a better word a
type of plaque or something in in your
noggin fleas yes so so actually when you
sleep you're cleaning you're detoxing
your body you're cleaning your brain
you're actually clearing your set yes
like deleting all the trash that's right
so you're literally cleaning your brain
and that's why you know when you don't
sleep for a long period of time you can
go crazy
well yeah literally go that's a form of
torture that we stew do to people up I
still do a lot of people here but these
women have drowned their kids in a
bathtub and they're all six kids because
they've been taking care of the kid
themselves and they're broke and they
got six kids they go crazy
they just go crazy that's a [ __ ]
bummer yeah do you think certain
receptors like turn off and like turn on
like different parts of your brain start
firing sleeping when you don't sleep oh
also when you're sleeping they say that
your body and your brain are just as
active or more active so you're you're
not only dreaming in a different form
yeah you're cleaning you're going
through all this stuff you know what
it's very rare I remember my dreams
that's about to end do you remain - no
until I think back but they're always
vivid sometimes they're super vivid and
they're correct but I know how often is
that I don't know I very often like I'll
smoke weed before I go to bed - help me
shut down again at nine o'clock I smoked
some weed
zone out on it show or something but
it's very rare I remember my dreams have
you ever might do yeah their sexual
really yes but other than that not much
man
Wow and I will wake up with a with a
diamond heart dawn like knocking things
over diamond oh yeah I can cut glass
with this yeah I wake up with a [ __ ]
bloody dick
it's never the Blood Diamond sniffing
out have you lead me to the pisser have
you uh have you uh do you remember any
of it at any dream you've ever had like
a really vivid one uh I what was weird
is I had crazy dreams ice take a
supplement this so old school Cody
diamond Christian Allen will remember
this so well earlier Marshall we still
all take a supplement call
I had it and I just lost it
soma tomax oh yeah soma soma tomax and
but this is before you got super poplar
I'm Air Force Griffin kind of
recommended it then we all started
taking it and it would come it look like
came from Mars it was like this reddish
pink rock but it's like moist yeah they
came to this white and blue bottle like
you take this and it helps you
rejuvenate it helps your growth hormone
and IGF
you would take it and you were [ __ ]
out
sleepy out was expensive to taste pretty
it was tasted really good too Wow so you
take it and then you'd have the most
vivid dreams ever really yeah I remember
I'd be fighting it was when I was
fighting I remember these dreams I'd
already win the it was like oh the week
of the fight and I take this stuff and I
go through though I win the fight and
win it like this cool fascinating I'd
like all that that's how this is going
down to the sign them so my tongue I
tell me so metallics never have happened
that way but there is there it is they
changed the it it used to be used to
have some [ __ ] melon mallet melatonin
oh you talking about professor that
sweet [ __ ] millet no that's not the
whole food tablets military what I just
bring that up melatonin no oh my grandma
takes them well have talking about some
serious [ __ ] rate change they changed
the formula it's not the same anymore I
don't know what they did I think they
had such good [ __ ] at that guy
this gave me to mainstream so I would
take that I remember I took it and I and
I have to stop that I got something I
woke up like super sad cuz it wasn't
real I had a dream on this where a
family member died like I think it was
like my dad or mom or my brother I
called him the next morning like got so
sad so ever had that yeah someone dies
and he calmly came in you're good like
yeah I'm fine why it's like just check
yep I've had that I've had I had the
craziest dream once the one I'll never
forget what were your [ __ ] your body
what some toys you mean my right so moto
Mac's gay you mean mine
you mean never taken the melatonin
tablet
well there's a recurring character my
dreams called tax and he's got a heavy
moustaches that's the guy you're talking
about it's weird bro it's like whenever
I fall asleep when I take the supplement
called water I drink gay and I just hear
him go pick a spot on the wall I'm going
to town Zach but I forget what I was
listening to it was someone where they
had it yeah so many phones go to Mike's
gay edition it's a tough to get black
market you may not be gay but how about
dreaming oh I'm sleepwalking whoops such
a dick there is is it but I've had III
can't remember if I see this is where it
gets weird cuz you have so much
information coming I can't remember if I
had this conversation with someone or if
I listen to someone have this
conversation I had that where they
dreamt that they had a gay encounter in
their dream that was me I remember I
remember I remember that don't you
remember that oh [ __ ] it's all finally
kids yes
I've had years ago yes I've had that
dream before dude oh my god I gotta talk
about this cuz I've had a dream where
I'm like where I'm with the guy and I'm
like the guy though I think it was I
don't remember the whole things have
blur I really don't remember but we'd
have to go back if somebody knows what I
said I don't remember but somebody
because irony I've had this more than
once where I'm literally I'm like I'm
like dude I'm straight bro but I'm
dating this dude now and I'm making out
with him and he wants to [ __ ] and I
don't even know how to do this and I'm
like well I can we do [ __ ] but I it's
not so in your dream you're actually
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm like I'm I'll make it
out to like a row I'm his boyfriend
living with him and I'm in the kitchen
it's so we're allocating $4 ass hanging
up yes I know you're making like ravioli
I don't know I have this dream too oh
wait but I mean I'm not in the dream I'm
straight and I'm a little grossed out
but I'm doing it anyway because it's I'm
like well I guess this is the thing now
know what they know this is what I do
have a severe pressure decisions I've
made it is really weird but I think what
an expert will say is subconsciously
you've thought about that all of us
because your brain just doesn't pop in
there well no I thought I'd been
watching porn then then you're watching
it and like it's like this you know dude
hitting this girl from the back and then
the girl flips arms dick and well right
yes have you been I'm like oh bro
well first of all have you ever gone
here if you've gotta belong here yeah if
you go to you porn there's sometimes in
the videos that your little ones
recommend it dude there's a there's a
guy on down like hey how'd that sneak in
there and then what did I click on that
by accident for two seconds I got a C
dude I saw the greatest I saw the
greatest it was these these guys this
guy's in jail and they're all ha what is
this bro this is a this is a video that
I swear everybody I swear to God get a
pop I don't care at all hey hey I don't
care in the Haggadah my it popped into
the that you know once in a while it's
like you're like what's this gay video
doing and this guy comes in to jail and
they're holding his legs and the splits
and they're just [ __ ] going to town
the guy goes he's going hey hey you guys
cut it out as they're of course and I'm
and I was like but to me that's
something I've never I like I think to
me I'm like Jesus Christ look at that
that I know like this is what people are
in right and like oh that's what it's
like on the other side of the fence
yes you know I'm saying if there's no
real fancy but even like I agree they'd
see that's not gay I think you just like
that's what they're agitating you're
like oh yeah it's like when I you know
when there's something like satanic or
something like that like I'll be into it
because I'm like I just want to see
something like that [ __ ] is so dark
yeah I'm the exact opposite I'm gonna
peek over the fit cut you guys mean toe
and that's [ __ ] yeah and now you're
no yours but sex but mine's no no I'm bi
like other stuff no I'm gay so that's
the thing that's the that's that's all
I'm saying your mistake yeah yeah it's
all saying is I'm what I mean is I'm gay
and I fantasize about guy-on-guy
[ __ ] that's all I mean that's that's
what I'm trying see I knew I heard it
somewhere but I heard it again from some
from someone else I'm like a legit like
sorts like a TED talk or something all
the time I'm having gay
dreams and what that does that make you
homosexual and the expert said no no you
and I are straight as [ __ ] let's be
honest yeah we're straight as [ __ ] I
mean unless we're on an island for three
days but the thing is this like Kenya do
what's right but you and I also can
appreciate the [ __ ] out of masculine
beauty any more than me sure but but but
if there's a really good-looking guy
right oh as a man oh it's all sure not
only that because of who I am and when
he's with his girl and you go well that
girl must love banging that guy cuz if I
was a girl I'd bang that guy not me well
typically you know typically if it's a
really handsome guy in a smoke show girl
I'll go dude
check out that that guys [ __ ]
handsome is riot or what I'll say is if
there's no show girl and it's really hot
guy I'll go
hey can I suck your boyfriend's dick so
I'll say that but as a straight guy I
don't know what I heard it but to Bieber
time I will they have these fantasies of
not fantasies but dream dreams with the
other set I don't fit doesn't make me
it's never been a turn-on to me to think
about you said you have a recurring
dream where you're in the kitchen in an
apron with your a stick out the back and
you get the [ __ ] that I didn't talk
about me I see what you said no I didn't
why do I have a hard-on right now on the
companion we're talking about how
there's so much like molestation and
child abuse in Hollywood yeah and for
the reason I went Cal and got abused as
a kid in camp and being Rogen could not
stop laughing I went I went either got
his do get my boy went either got his
dick sucked where's friend guys dicks oh
yeah and my friend darling can't stop
laughing yeah why is it funny that
counting up Melissa how weird is that
yeah oh you would laugh too because in
this case first of all I didn't there's
a huge difference between getting like
spelt up like this guy did and getting
[ __ ] big difference also the guy tried
to suck on my dong and I said I was like
oh my god he got his dick honey gots got
his dick sucked but here's the thing bin
time that's still that's still
molestation I just I just don't
but I wasn't trompe personally just
because I not because it's not
traumatize it was not traumatic to me I
went right to my mom and I was like um
such insights will drive is me right I
know you everyone deals in a different
way
I
here you Oh your hands felt good well I
hear you
you got molested yeah I hear you two
here you're really supporting me right
monitor hashtag me too no I I don't know
but women team I'm not bright I'm not
bringing light to it at all but the
weirdest hop on and I just blurted out
Cal got molested as a kid and we all
started just bless though because you're
not you're fine yeah I guess yeah dump
Davidoff talks to this tells the story
about that a guy goes sure he was there
I got baseball cards devil wanted
baseball cards and the guys I'll show
you to him if you show me your dick he
goes all right and he pulls a dick out
in the guy I guess played with it and he
goes you guys call it a mana station I
call it a [ __ ] good deal [ __ ] true
story Pete Rose good yeah yeah but not
to make light of Abhi's no not at all
but there's yeah do you don't do you
feel well go ahead don't be scared III
just talk about I just think you see
with this hashtag me to thing women deal
with this [ __ ] on a level I remember
when I was um I was with all the new
guys patty Jenkins patty Jenkins who
some new director but I know that guy I
can tell you stories about that guy ever
stories about that guy forever too and
that's a fact that's the problem right
but but let's talk about that too but
one of the things is that like I was in
New York City and I was young man I was
when I was with patty and patty was
walking down the street and a dude was
great just like that and she didn't even
notice and I go I'm gonna go oh I oh I'm
gonna fight today I make a beeline I'm
gonna punch that [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
face that's what she deals patty goes
whoa what are you doing I go that guy is
whistling and going cute which I have
never done I would never do that in a
million [ __ ] years right and I know
you would never but this dude and I go
and I don't know anyone who does oh dude
I've seen it yeah I don't know I go but
you're being a bully you're being a
piece of [ __ ] so I know she's on you're
going like this to a girl like that and
my girl so I make a beeline I'm gonna
you know I'm a hothead right I go I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this guy she goes
what are you doing I go what she goes
you think that doesn't happen every day
follow me stands and 15b feet behind me
and sure enough patty hasn't asked to
she had yes yes do you get it a lot of
MJ you get all the time right yeah it's
super weird especially when I would like
take buses and trains everywhere like
yeah you're sitting there like trying to
get around and then all of a sudden some
creepy dude and what's the worst is when
they hover and they they don't go away
when you're like oh thank you like bye
yeah he's being a beast being a
predators but also training and I'm sure
none of the [ __ ] army are [ __ ]
weird like that but you have a friend
who is like that has it has it ever
worked MJ were you like did you just
[ __ ] you what's up me what is your
number has it ever worked no never in
the history of mankind has anyone that
stops a relationship off someone cat oh
no it's sick though you know it's sick
thought it would work on guys
like if girls were like driving buying
cars going hey baby we'd be like
different animal different animal
because they can't harm us of course
they can't [ __ ] this up your safety
words we put out when you can't defend
yourself it's a hundred percent
different and then you get these creepy
directors like James Toback who I've
been hearing word I've been hearing
stories about him again forever and it's
a profile but when I see the picture
yeah yeah yeah we can go through
director pictures right now I'll use
[ __ ] more but you know somebody said
I was talking to these two people about
it yesterday and I said cuz I'm talking
to a woman that he did this to yesterday
arm to my neighbor and she had she was
over with her husband her kids she's not
yet she's no she's actually got a PhD in
comparative literature and he she tells
me a story about a guy and she gotta go
what was his name she goes James Toback
I go I've been hearing stories about
that guy from axis remember I lived in
New York so I know so many actresses he
did that to two other women that I know
so so but that's just me I don't what
he's doing the same thing once thing did
so what he would do is he would get he'd
say you really captivate me I wonder
what you would do to me on camera here's
my credentials he's credentialed so
these actresses with cool and then he'd
have you come over at 12 cuz he doesn't
sleep come over at 12:00 at night you
show up in a robe and then he would he
would do the same kind of thing he'd
have you pinch his nipples and stare him
according to this and look it in the eye
or whatever Indies he'd try to get off
what for me that's not a guy who's
that's not a guy who's into women that's
a guy who's into manipulation and power
so yeah when you get tired in a very
vulnerable position and now you jerk off
what are you do something like that
that's humiliating them and creating
them well I talk to you he has it's over
and over 38 women non-stop Wow what they
do I thought to Johanna about it who you
know she grew up in entertainment she's
on Univision and tell him all these
different stations and this major I
asked her I'm it has ever happened to
you and she is what has that ever
happening shows oh yes
yeah his three female I know whose
entertainment has had an encounter like
this or what are you kidding me so she
told me a story this this guy everyone
would know a big guy who runs a big
[ __ ] company and she said she was in
the East Coast I don't give it away just
in case I don't know but she was in the
East Coast and she was working and the
guys like man would really love to
connect like I think you could do this
and inside some tips I can help you I
went so did you go to his office she
goes no we did over dinner and I went
you don't think that's it and I said I
said I'm not I'm not advocating what he
did I said you don't think that's mixing
length a little bit she was I can't go
to dinner really guy went on it was it a
it was like a Friday night she's young
went to me that's to me that's mixing
lines a little bit because as a man if
let's say you're an attractive girl an
officer you're a very attractive girl
and I can help you and I go let's do
dinner on Friday night over drinks and
you show up and then after that I go
let's go to the room and talk I agree
you have to take and I'm not asking but
you have to take some sort of exact will
join wit because I was painting women as
victims only and that's very common and
I can act will join when you're the
nicest person in the world like and when
you're nice and you look like that to me
that's a look and again I'm not how can
mean this [ __ ] but I'm ashamed if it's a
Friday night you're dressed to the nines
you agree to this dinner at 10 o'clock
at night we're having drinks and you
dress like that and you're friendly as
[ __ ] yeah come as a as a male who loves
women I'm not woman as a guy who loves I
go mmm
yeah I might have a [ __ ] cha there
you go and we're not sexual right and
we're sitting together for two hours
yeah and we're not talking about work
you're [ __ ] you're talking about your
friends and couldn't do more hop culture
couldn't agree more Hawkman couldn't
agree more buddy and I think I think you
burned all the bad fairy you bring up
such an important because yeah because
if I win let's go to dinner Friday night
over drink to it whoa no no I'll see
Monday at Dobson no problem yes exact
all business I wouldn't bark up that
tree right gotcha
yes and you can't but you go yeah see a
fret this hot spot in Miami let's do it
yes that's a date that's a date and all
is it a date but if you're if you're a
little Otis hotel room yeah you can't
blame a boss or any man any man who is
working with somebody and he's attracted
to them he's attractive oh I'm in a
position of power and I could help you
but I also like you you're also
beautiful you're also really attractive
you I'm also maybe lonely I also would
love to date you or whatever it might be
and then I ask you then we we start to
work together and we hit it off and
we're getting along and now what happens
is I like you how many people need at
work yeah most people that's we get
married or that's her you need at some
work function and keeping something
common yeah now the problem is when that
guy in power goes listen you me suck my
dick summarize promotion tracks I'm a
bad person Iraq that's different that's
what if the boss goes listen that's
where that's your line you're doing a
great job I get all that
I don't be taken out of context Friday
night I grab drinks not not work-related
I grab drinks yes yeah I don't think
that's I don't think that sexual
harassment the problem also there is
this that for a woman who's working in a
boss starts to hit on you and you're
just working and then he asks you out
but you're not interested now you know
that if you say no you're gonna pay for
it even in a subtle way see that how
we're running that's a core and with
that we're Harvey Weinstein these stupid
[ __ ] in Hollywood they're all over
there they're predators but most but
that's that's when you talk about bad
guys they're coming out jerking off and
that's the exception I think in general
all the guys whether they're in power of
position aren't bad guys right these
guys are seeing the worst of the worst
yes cuz they're going hey not only if
you don't do this I'm gonna [ __ ] your
career oh yes if you don't do this
you're not gonna same opportunities as
your example but we because she will
suck my dick you're being a bigger bad
guys but if a boss asks you out let's
say I was single MJ and I go hey you
want to go out on Saturday night and you
go no I'm like I cool and then Monday
the
are different when treating like [ __ ] or
I'm like yo don't I'm a pay cut like
what the [ __ ] where you get fired yeah
you get replaced we don't need you
anymore that there you can see that's
Divya yeah we know I mean I know several
women who have gone for interviews where
they needed jobs and the guy asked them
out after and then of course they don't
get the job because they don't want to
go out with that's happen to a former
employer yeah we have friend of ours a
friend of ours is really a diet it's a
very we had to be compassionate to and
we can't get into this mob mentality
because not all guys are scumbags not
all guys in power are [ __ ] and
sometimes you're in power and you just
like somebody and you're attracted to
him and you ask him out and maybe you do
go to dinner and maybe you do go back to
the hotel room or maybe you don't but
you try to get it back to the time
because you're so attracted to her and
you like her that doesn't make you a
scumbag man it doesn't even make you
somebody taking advantage of your power
there's a lot of guys [ __ ] it up
right but there are a lot of guys were
just it just makes it a new mystery
makes you [ __ ] a new mainstream we
better not lose our humanity because
when you join it is what I talked about
my stand-up now when you join a team
when you join a team and you identify
with that team you're either all in or
you're all out and that's what happens
when you get cast into these different
groups and that's what I think the the
extreme the people running this
narrative and driving this narrative in
a lot of the fanatics but the rock the
reason I like some of this narrative
toby is because like what's this in it's
not surprising but like with Harvey
Weinstein or the souther dude who what's
his name Starr back everyone else do
I've heard those stories for years and
no one's ever said anything it came out
well they did but we didn't know what to
do with it so you know what they might
help so but not but now I feel like do
these scumbags who are [ __ ] on all
males in entertainment they're gonna get
found out because now women don't have
to be so scared even guys like dude it's
happened to everybody yes and you have
child star actors money gets happened to
me and if people in the music business
you have the the singer from the
Pussycat called Pussycat Dolls going
we're basically prostitutes and music
business which got spun around non-stop
so what does that say though about human
beings not even the business but so what
does that say about male-female dynamic
and what does it say about sexuality in
other words if this has always been the
case and always gone on and we've all
navigated this and it's a reality what
where do we go from here so even though
we know about it and I guess now you can
publicly shame people which means you
can suppress behavior but you're not
gonna change behavior are you
you can certainly well you're gonna
change behavior but it's because it's
being at the pet has to be well under
but also if people know they can't get
away with us still gonna do it I don't
think so then that's a good thing right
so that's why I'm saying I'm coming out
be like okay you want to do that if you
[ __ ] with my career in any facet I'm
gonna go on whatever show I want blast
out you're not gonna have a career
anymore
or you want put in your contract I'll
suck your dick I'm gonna take that
contract I'm gonna go to CNN I might
take that contract I'm going Joe Rogan
yeah I mean whatever you want to do we
can play that game I'm gonna [ __ ] your
first of all those cousin allies and how
the people that had no voice in power
have power yeah which is good those guys
can't play that gaming yeah cuz those
those what you see with those kind of
guys is the massive number of women that
come and go oh yeah he did that to me
too and you're like dude you have a
major issue here talk about and you're
finished but you know should be should
be when you're that guy but what do
people did they [ __ ] make small and
make feel good yeah I agree but let's
say there's some young actor today who's
just getting started and let's say next
year he has a huge movie it's one of
those weird Sundance movies that wins
the Oscar and he becomes super famous
and the first girl he tries to hit on in
a negative way like harden when she goes
[ __ ] you I'm not doing that guys all
right can't do that can't get away with
that that's not happening I'm not gonna
act like that I'm gonna go a different
route I'm not gonna [ __ ] with actors and
actresses anymore you know I'm saying
yeah my dance star - yeah but before
with hardened Weinstein like he just was
a predator on the actresses where before
you know if Harvey Weinstein did this
with prostitutes yeah it's all good baby
that's that's the world that's he paid
for right but he's doing with these
people it's a power position huh I'm
saying if the young director and now we
know if you're gonna act like this
you're [ __ ] you don't have a career as a
director maybe he's not gonna do it
anymore
yeah and that's the good thing yeah man
I I piss so hard let's let's piss let's
go piss everyone's go do some piss and
then we'll come back anyway that's a
piss so bad you gotta pee
Jack here's the question they'll be so
like the Harvey Weinstein the other
what's the other clown they gotta kick
James fair back James James Toback how
many so they they probably took how many
swings oh good and when I say swings
that's a metaphor oh my god I mean how
this was that blue thunder what their
success rate is this was a but that's
what's scary well there's always going
to be people who are desperate or who
are in a position where they can't say
no because of a thousand reasons and so
so you know if you throw enough against
the wall something is going to stick
it's just the weight but there's a lot
of large not especially when you're
influenced in careers worth less than so
just so people realize and entertainment
especially as an actor I would say I bet
comedians there might be similar less
than one of one percent making actual
living yes being an act yes and I know I
know this so intimately as you know
because being especially in New York and
being for the years that I spent not
working and the years I saw and was with
people especially women in my acting
classes and on auditions and through my
who have who who dealt with it but also
just let's just take acting is like who
are really talented and just never
worked for a lot of reasons then you get
one break you get one break if you get
that one break after think about this
okay so you're 30 and you get one break
this is the break this is the break and
you're coming up to speak to the most
powerful man in Hollywood and he's got a
script for you and he wants you in his
movie okay and you've been waiting
tables and you've done some bit stuff
but you know your town never made put it
all your [ __ ] time you're 30 you've
never looked better you never felt
better you're at the top of your game
you're an or you're an actress you can
do it you can navigate any role and you
get up there and this is the big danger
and then you go we're meeting at the
Beverly Hills Hotel but why are you
having me come up to your room that's
weird
oh okay maybe we can work on it and
maybe there's and all of a sudden he's
in a robe and he pulls his dick out what
would you do be I hold on now listen now
just yeah
I'm gonna [ __ ] in line I mean this let's
say you're 30 year old Bryan Callen yeah
and your dream has been to be an actor
you thought you're gonna be the next
yeah never told you that it's so [ __ ]
up anyway yeah yeah you're the next Tom
Hanks right this the biggest director in
the world let's say it's George Lucas
sure and this is before Star Wars came
out and goes listen here's 10 for
driving me [ __ ] nuts
it's 1983 or whatever yeah you're young
as [ __ ] it's 1983 you're George Lucas
and he goes your agent goes hey George
Lucas wants to meet me the barrel here
hotel he said meet him in his room right
like I said about he's like I don't know
maybe let's you be [ __ ] CP for
whatever in the can I don't know it's
weird he's even asked you to be there
sure maybe Chewbacca some sure yeah you
go in there yeah George Lucas not the
most handsome guy in the world is George
Lucas Peschel ii the tiny little skin it
smells like come on he's like clump a
cigar right yeah and he is like an RTD
to and some weird suits behind them fry
stormtrooper suit behind him whatever
you know Darth Vader mask on but he's
sitting there he's in his robe baby
birds hanging out the front no no you
gotta is that life saver hanging out the
front light saber just flesh colors like
it's hanging out the front yes Brian how
you doing brother
all right listen there's some force
driving me [ __ ] crazy okay can I just
I gotta stop you can see I don't mind
that dumb I don't mind that
yeah we'll get to that we will get to
that here's a fortune I mean that's what
this demands we start shooting the movie
yeah if you just take those city skyline
teeth you have there and suck this
George Lucas dick uh give me the next
Star Wars franchise for how long I don't
know it'd be super successful okay
that's all you just gotta do it once and
I'll leave you alone
gotcha that's a cue just give me a
second please I knew we just call me I
know well let's say you call me let's
say you call me I go give me a second I
had a feeling this was gonna be the case
and I appreciate that and I would I
would say I have a friend who wants how
about and we'll go let's let's let's say
it we're gonna call it weird let's do
the call yeah no no no you don't
understand already I've already planned
this you're you're in the hallway and
guess what you dressed in drag you dress
what do I got a blonde wig on lipstick
your mouth is you got your well ship I'm
not done wait what do I get out of this
I'm gonna tell you you come in
and I go now George I got a woman who's
gonna help you out with this and you're
gonna come in and I go she's gonna help
you out with your perversion let George
Lucas a bad example because he's not a
pervert he's amazing I'm just saying but
every Weinstein let's say Harvey wants
if Harvey wants a big deal however does
Harvey Weinstein's Ted
I'd say he didn't do start well right
now you can make or break my career with
a phone call this woman right here
her name is Brendan ax and Brendan ax
Bren Dina's gonna give you a little what
for and then I would have you [ __ ]
toss him around beat him up and jujitsu
the [ __ ] out of him just walk no no I
have what you're missing the point you
press lemon till he had to suck his own
dick you understand I go well we're not
gonna secretary but he's gonna bend your
well let's wrap this bit up all I'm
saying is if a big-time director when
you were 30 struggling yeah was like yo
you're gonna be the next Harrison Ford
all you got to do is Jack me off with
your feet yeah would you do it no just
old to you a dream what am i sweating
[ __ ] wedding and now George Lucas asked
you to Jack mouth with his feet in the
past I mean the T answer is I've never
been that desperate so I don't know but
I will tell you that I know a famous guy
who was super he was broke his [ __ ]
before he made it taking a piss and a
guy came in and goes I'll suck your dick
for 1,500 bucks and my friend was like
oh he's straight as hell you know god
damn it's so much money right now that's
so much money and he really had to think
about it
yeah like is the battle and and then
he's religious so he was like I don't
think this is I think I'm gonna pay for
this later so tonight he wanted the
money so buddy goes I'm not doing it and
he walked away so I you know the you've
never been hit on or anything the truth
is now I'm not cute enough I mean I have
but not like that
really I know a guy you know you and I
know a guy right now and we'll talk
about it after all fair you're gonna be
very surprised who is a bad [ __ ]
and he had a photographer basically try
to bully him into pretty girl some [ __ ]
nope hey don't do different guys really
I feel like your love is deep crap Oh
Frank has but see Frank stuff
Frank is a guy who is just too tough
he's an okay man
Franco punchy Frank for sure II know
that Frank will what punch he's not if
he's that prey my buddy bob was the
Soloflex guy Bob Williams bring up Bob
Williams Soloflex this is my buddy and a
very famous very famous [ __ ] agent
who I tried to be with back in New York
he was saying he was the guy at one
point and he grabbed my buddy's dick and
Bob doesn't play that Bob punched him in
the stomach
he just went boom and hit him in stomach
and the guy goes still images and he
felt down but yeah and he fell down and
basically there is there's Bob look at
him see him climbing a rope right there
we call them strongest man in the world
not much this one right there yeah thank
you so much well I will find a picture
will find a picture of them that's Bobby
Robert yeah oh yeah Robert Williams
there is hands muscies would you anyway
the point is he I'm really grabbed how
he longs dick how would you do that you
could die the thing I said well how he
longs its own God Hulk Hogan said the
same thing well I think that you're you
know some guys will do that because
they're guys they don't know if you're
gay they're gonna try it but for me with
their wives yeah I don't know that's
very sweet but you know it's just I
think they get away with so much they
know you're not gonna do [ __ ] if you
wanna be in the movies I don't know
I think they guard they're always
perverts in every industry and there are
always people who are gonna take
advantage of that and are desperate and
they're gonna do that so that we're
talking about the movie industry I think
this happens everywhere with people and
in in that case you know I've never been
put in that position really so I'm I'm
lucky I can't believe it all been put in
that position
who's your a little twinkling pie you
know it almost makes you sad doesn't it
yeah it wasn't cute or nothing
how is it a rough kid I wore short
shorts yeah you are no one ever say or
anybody know there's nothing I was in
Boy Scouts I hung around after-hours not
my parents didn't pick me up on nothing
I got football practice all the goddamn
time solo maybe because you were no one
[ __ ] with me yeah you're just super
friendly I'm not like a story or
something Maddie I was like I was Chatty
Cathy like am
nothing nothing ever well the thing
about a lot of people who go through
this they don't talk about it because
they feel it's so humiliating to them
yeah that's so that's why this coming to
light switch in Hollywood and like you
said happens everywhere yeah so I think
you you asked this question so what do
we do about if that's you know I'm
saying
you said if this is well you know I
don't say it's in our nature cuz these
guys you know way it is right in a way
like well so let's put it this way in a
way like an older stronger more powerful
male has always been the one like if you
look at chimpanzees they've always been
the one who get the they get the sexual
spoils right yeah there is a degree of
that in in it seems to be like the
amount of elsewhere here are sexualized
at a young age and like it's it's very
very interesting to see how sexuality is
very layered very complex and and and
decadent I mean people when they can get
away with it how many children how many
people have a story including me of boys
girls have a story of when they were
sexualized against their wishes or their
will at a very early age that probably
is as old as time and probably is that
though I think that probably our biology
biology starts speaking to us way before
our socialization does so in other words
there's a social taboo against having
sex for example at 50 with a 14 year old
girl right but in a lot of societies and
cultures that especially historically
well historically if a girl was reached
sexual maturity 12 13 14 a period she
she was betrothed to a an older
wealthier man Game of Thrones oh yes so
you were a guy look at look at this look
at war looking at it the first thing
that they would do is come in and
children women right and not even then a
lot of times it would just happen
through trade a lot of times it would
happen through contact and before you
know it you've got you know
interbreeding so you're you're a guy who
doesn't have a lot of money but you have
a beautiful daughter and you want to
allow yourself with a more powerful
family and you say honey you're 13
you're gorgeous
I'm giving you to the wealthier
landowner that's always
how it would be but you'd but having you
hungry involved not me well what I'm
saying is that there's a biology that we
haven't evolved from so human beings
become sexual so you have a teacher
whether it's a matter of female who is
biologically sexually attracted to this
younger person would want someone say
that a mental handicap well or it's or
as you say it's actually it's or it's a
product or it's a an offshoot of a
certain kind of natural phenomenon like
and it affects a certain subset of the
population right so so we know this
because the evidence is overwhelming
correct so if that's the case then my
question becomes with if obviously you
want to protect people from being
sexualized against their will right
although sex is so [ __ ] always isn't sex
always dicey and scary disease you don't
know the person how's it gonna work are
you gonna function well are they gonna
freak out there's just so many things
sex requires a great deal of personal
responsibility as we get older between
two people it's not just the man just
said as you get older yeah well so so so
what I'm saying is that yes I know the
reason why and you know whether these
armies and back in the day medieval
times whenever when they go into a city
or village and raping you know take
everyone it's awfully against their will
yes so even today as we evolved you
can't have a fourteen-year-old who's
into [ __ ] Bubble Guppies
yeah well fourteen year olds are sexual
though so a lot of 14 year olds are
having sex or doing sexual things right
so now you got a 14 year old and she
meets the 18 year old the senior this
happens all the time
and then maybe she's got no parents at
home and she's 15 and she gets she meets
the 23 year old drug dealer who's giving
her stuff this happens again all the
time and in a way they're 23 and 15 30
and 15 historically not uncommon
historically marriage historically
children's network a movie just cuz that
story not to me did a lot of [ __ ] that
was [ __ ] up historically well it's not
right to me because I think 15 to me
feels way too young for somebody to is
it not I don't know
they're not right for you because the
way you were raised and you're educated
so we know that 16 years old was it 16
is age of consent 16 in a lot of states
yeah 16 right let's think about how
young that is I'm 50 so they're say
let's say just for shits and giggles I
might be 18 you know it's it's 16 in
some states at 17 I think in Vegas
whatever the case that's very young to
me that's right to me it's very very
young there it is 18 yeah hold up the
age of 12 is the mid range of content
Wow consent with age at which there are
no restrictions except 18 sex with
someone 12 to 18 is not illegal per se
but consider what fussing cities is 12
how old is so there you go though but
because they did it's kind of crazy I
can't imagine well I think that's to
protect so if you have a twelve-year-old
that might be to protect a
fifteen-year-old kid who has sex with a
12 year old you know III don't know the
- 16 what's that Canada is 16 that's the
consent yeah so I can be 50 holed up in
Mexico it's complex
typically Mexican states have primary
age of consent which may be as low as 12
sexual conduct with persons below the
age is always illegal it's really it's
really Wow because those things reflect
in my opinion the haters of consent in
countries of Central America range from
14 to 18 yeah got 14 just doesn't make
sense Europe by the way has always been
that way Europe you would always see
super young girls with but there's that
five 40 year old but they're they're
older than right they're way older than
we are so historically they go off those
old-time yeah you'd see at the beach I
remember I was in that I wouldn't wear I
was just doesn't seem right maybe it's
the way I was raised me I'm just not
accustomed to it you know well from me
either by band mainly because I always
feel like I that's a responsibility that
I take have you ever seen a 14 I'm like
look at them I hate them I sure as for
you're having but that's again by the
way that's also because I am attracted
as are you to women so in other words I
like I like a mature woman because that
that's what I'm into right I like about
you means mature like you know I want a
woman who really knows what the [ __ ]
she's doing right I want a woman who's
really into it on her own I don't want
it I got 25 26 27 30 35 40 if they're in
that's that's attractive to me right so
and I'm not blaming guys for being
attracted to an 18 year old girl got a
nice [ __ ] all the way around yeah
they'll break your back 100% harder
percent um what I'm what I'm trying to
say is that you are drawn to what you're
drawn to right you're drawn to what
you're drawn to as a mental illness if
you're drawn to so and younger then well
I don't I don't know I I do think that
if you're attracted to if you're a grown
man you're attracted to five year olds
10 year olds you're a pedophile and you
need not to be walking around the
streets that's very dangerous
and again that's a phenomenon oh and by
the way there's a lot of science about
that they say that that might be
neurological a great deal of pedophiles
apparently are left-handed which is one
of the reasons they think some of it
might be neurological there's this you
know shows Netflix called minehunters
yeah if it might have you watched I've
not so mine hunters is drama that right
it's a drama it's basically how the FBI
branch came about finding serial killers
because these columns
I forget not not serial killers there's
something continuous killers something
then the Kemper name serial killers and
how this guy who basically was into
psychology and sociology how him and
this team established this department
going hold on there's more going on here
we can try and figure out what their
next move is because there's patterns in
their behavior and when you look at
serial killers I'm super into this when
you look into the like serial killers
show we got some flack cuz when we're
talking about that movie monster with
Charlie Stern she played what's the
serial killers name the female serial
killer Ilene warned us I mean warned us
how we like you know monsters because
that's what society made her yeah well
if you look at every serial killer you
can make a movie called monster about
every season of them Society and the way
they were raised well they actually know
that serial killers brains are a little
bit different in a lot of cases so their
amygdala isn't as developed they can't
feel so we do know that a lot of serial
killers have a form of brain damage they
have a an inability to empathize or feel
and their only way to to relate to other
people is through power and that's where
you know at least that's what I think
his name is Richard well there's a lot
of this this show gets into the best
show it's fascinating because that what
they do is they go and they talk to old
serial killers like what were you
thinking this well how were you raised
and they find these calm and kind of
connectors with all the serial killers
it's really funny starts off a little
slow though it does starts a little slow
David fingers to your me wrote zodiac
that movie that was really hot the
Zodiac killer did they never caught him
they think they know who he was there
was one guy who obsessed so badly on it
and they think they never was
he was acid he was a sadist and they had
interviewed him he they found squirrels
dead squirrels in his they found Lube
they found all kinds of weird [ __ ] in
his apartment and it was really really
really creepy and freakin so you know
killers are freaky yeah I don't mind
others pretty dope it's horrifying
because they call them Richard Walter I
think he labeled them excite [ __ ] they
get excited at the act of killing so a
lot of people like a lot of murders you
can really you can tell a lot about a
murder so if a guy Hashim yeah you
either David's your heads crushed in his
one blow that's like a guy he's like a
great white he came in to do exactly
revenge and kill you but then there are
the ones that you know get off on the
torture yeah you know terrible yeah she
jumps on current events oh wait let's
talk about I watch Cerrone I didn't i
watch i watch Cerrone and I know you
girls I fight John Piper and you you
kind of secretly were worried about
Donald in that forward yeah and I could
understand cuz you were kind of
tight-lipped about it but you were kind
of looking at me sideways like he's a
monster and not a good fight for him and
then I I watched that and that guy is
just bill I mean he's just a [ __ ]
beast for me though as a fight fan I
can't see what he's doing
like you can probably see it like I
can't see why he's able to connect that
way and why he was you first of all he's
bigger he's bigger framed I get it but
also Donald's fought bigger guys before
yeah um he just looked he looked a lot
like Conor McGregor his style to me
looked like a lot like Conor McGregor
the way he was standing
his head was up and so so but he just
seemed to have a secret that that gets a
secret I think that's actually Domitian
what he did and even Donald say goes I
wasn't off and have a bad night he's
that [ __ ] good
yes let's see so what was it a years of
training at a high level
kickboxing right he's phenomenal so
being able I would measure dizzy that's
a world-class striker yeah yeah there's
no secret it isn't Donald a world-class
striker it's different
Donald MacDonald was as decorated as
this guy was in strike it got you Donald
is a phenomenal mixed martial artist
strike a bit
Donald was in a world champion Cake Boss
so it's a striking thing right in the
guy's world class but to be fair and I
did not call this I thought it was a bad
fight for Donald for a number of reasons
because we don't know who dare until is
Donald you know if he wants to get a
title shot this isn't the way to do it I
know he wants to fight but you know dear
until unranked when he look into him
he's a [ __ ] nightmare nightmare and
it just I didn't see the pros and cons
for the pros and Donald's favorite even
if Don went in their head kicked them in
three seconds well yeah dude you father
guy was on right big deal right but
there's not many people we're gonna look
into well no you had kicked this guy
who's an amazing striker fascinating
story from Liverpool trained speaks
Portuguese and English trained in Brazil
for many years he's a freak you know so
the majority of the the fans aren't
gonna look into dare until yeah I made a
mistake
I knew a little bit dental I didn't know
it extensively how talented he was then
you look at me like oh my god don't what
are you doing Jesus so who's managing
he's like but Donald fight anybody
anywhere and that Darren tell said
that's why you don't actually know why
you love cowboy you love cowboy but
there's a double-edged sword and you
know Roy and I were talking about this
southern companion for cowboy how's this
and for cowboy because when you want to
be that I'll fight anyone anywhere I'll
be this guy be this guy well you never
get to a level where you're making that
life-changing money cuz you're never
champion you never get in pay per view
points cuz you're fighting anyone
anywhere yeah but those aren't the best
fights for you you're gone Cerrone I'm
I'll take that I do this I do that well
how how has that worked for anyone ever
I wonder if dare
until does the same thing to - wonderboy
to Robbie Lawler and finally it's tyron
woodley tougher with Tyrone Crist I was
gonna take you down or or he won't ills
tough takedown he sure sighs what is the
striking right um you know when you see
you know he'll walk through a guy before
listen anywhere he goes I I knew
Darren till was gonna walk through
cowboy you're full of [ __ ] cuz we'll get
there until earlier fights he wasn't
blowing your hair back no yet he had all
decisions he had a draw she wasn't
knocking your socks off okay but then
when you get the right matchup and you
see a striking his abilities and a size
and like alright we got something here
you know and I always give do UFC heat
where I go hey they never invest in
other products here they kind of did you
don't cowboy took the bait took the
fight but again how many people actually
saw this fight it was on flight path
yeah maybe 50,000 yeah yeah so his dear
tell superstar now no right no we with
the only for you who's in the guys who
were balls deep in MMA or like damn
genitals gonna be sick to watch and at
170 I mean to me as up-and-comer he's
not numero uno I want to watch that guy
fight more than anyone that meet you I
almost see what happens next
but I'm balls deep in MMA yeah my
brother but a lot of people running away
went wait how come we lost that's it
yeah I'll probably lost yeah yep yeah he
did
no one's time out there until it's no
Calvin lost yeah this is what happens
because I'm fight pass from the UFC I
replay that you know somehow I put that
on before the fight this weekend or in
the big November 4th ride I I don't know
what you do I think you sneaked that
fight in there somehow sure before the
prelims are something like check out why
he was calling out Mike Pence erm I
carry Mike Perry as opposed to calling
out I didn't understand that either no I
mean hey Robbie Lawler call out he did
interview about that he he goes he goes
listen a lot of people go if you beat
Donald yesterday I'll show you something
I haven't earned that I'm a cowboy gave
me this big shot that's that's one of
the reasons I [ __ ] like this kid
because he goes I haven't earned that
I'm not that guy who's gonna beat one
guy oh I want Tom shot give me this imma
prove to you how good I am
he goes you know I worked my way up I'm
gonna beat all of them but you know I'm
working my way
also if let's say fights Robbie Lawler
what's his contract 12 and 12 no no you
beat you so now you're undefeated you
just beat Donald I don't know what how
many find some offense contract now you
get Mike Perry some great matchup for
him but Mike Perry has a fight which is
a tough fight for my prey but then you
get Mike great match for and they beat
him now you renegotiate cuz now you find
top five anyway you're paid like there
but when you jump to the top right away
like I did yeah then you fighting these
legends who are getting hundreds of
thousands of dollars millions of dollars
you're not you can pay peanuts even if
you beat them yeah it's right you might
get a bonus but snot life-changing right
so for him he's going back to smart yeah
all right
that's very interesting West Cardinal
[ __ ] yeah yeah I watched a lot of his
face they were not that exciting all
right but for table you know it's three
losses in a row it's a bummer
yeah but the striking that you're
dealing with a k1 European champion so
you go what's the secret the secret is
working your ass off
wow that secret is I got to get myself
to [ __ ] you're a Liverpool start
training all right well a secret yeah
right or no maybe all right let me know
what do you got chin real quick how did
the chinder shirts go sales good good
you know we roll awesome by the way we
forgot to mention one guy's name is
Taylor Makara so it's Taylor underscore
MCA are a MCA Ari
yeah that's right so he's the one that
did the original concept of the shirt so
shut up shot I want to shout out to
Ashley who's a postal worker in Canada
who wept wept when she came to my show
after my show because she was like I
listen to you all day you're in labor
you guys are here and I deliver mail and
she and her husband's there and she
starts to cry because I'm I'm a tall
lady but I cry holy she was really tall
and tall very pretty and she but she
started crying and I was like and she
goes hi thank you and I was like I'm
gonna I have to mention this on on
fighting the kids so thanks Ashley
you're a doll chef Ashley yeah not
deliver that mail girl deliver that mail
what do you got Jen with dry eyes all
right the first one is actually a sad
story but it's super intriguing if you
know about this couple
is lost in Orange County no at Joshua
Tree what happened so they're a couple
went missing about three months ago and
they had a bed-and-breakfast that they
were staying at they didn't ever return
that their stuff was still there and
then that person called the authorities
saying like you know something's wrong
here so then turns out these people were
lost inside Joshua Tree and later on
they found the bodies three months later
and apparently the guy killed the girl
and killed himself so it's a
murder-suicide some dark [ __ ] but then
the more they looked into it the more
they investigated it looks like they
were about to die they had you know they
had rationed their food they couldn't
find water so the guy they believed the
guy actually was holding her you know he
actually put his shirt over her knee and
in her headband he made all the stuff a
love story because she probably injured
herself [ __ ] and she they're about to
die they're about to die so he held her
and killed her and they killed himself
and they were found in a embrace so both
their families are like yeah we thought
we believe that's what happened like it
wasn't some crazy awful God so Josh so
they're lost for a long time and they
were starving about the yeah there are
so many stories about like well then no
water that was the main thing in history
there are so many [ __ ] stories of
when the invading army is coming in and
the ruler the the the king or the Prince
knows this is for real would kill his
whole family because he knew they were
all gonna be taken as slaves or totally
you know and he would just you know
there's all that so many stories Lily
could rape you'd put them all to the
store and then kill himself and you know
it's just I could there's a famous story
about that but it's like [ __ ] man you
don't wanna be in that position I'm
sorry so those uh Special Forces guys
and they're like yeah man if there's a
chance of you getting caught by Isis
al-qaeda you just you finish yourself my
buddy he goes you don't you don't do not
want to be mixing with that he goes cuz
they're gonna humiliate you your
family's gonna see it yes you if there's
a chance and right before they do it you
do it yourself
yep like my buddy said that my buddy
said that's why I carries a pistol when
he's out there I was like Jesus my mom
being taken care I'm not being taken
hostage [ __ ] out of here that's a rough
way to go there was a Korean King
army admiral who uh who's gonna go to
war with some japanese and he knew that
they're gonna be outnumbered and die so
he killed his family before he went to
war because they knew that they would
end up torturing the family Koreans are
hardcore [ __ ] man yeah okay
next story some cheerleaders are caught
on a snapchat or this is actually
Instagram but they were using a snap
chat function to say something backwards
so they're saying something backwards
and what they're saying was surgeon cuff
and then when they played it forwards
alright so yeah they say it backwards
and when they use this app it turned out
to sound like f N word so I'll let you
guys here real quick hopefully it's not
too loud so you can tell it's they're
playing it backwards right but they
meant to do that
yeah but they thought they were being
sneaky that no one figure it out which
is Susan DuPage there's just a bunch of
white cheerleaders damn it the girl post
said yeah that's you can you imagine if
your daughter did that it's just a
farmer he imagine if your kid did that
like oh my god you're the worst social
media - that's what I'm saying
yeah so well yeah there's something with
your kid did this it can kind of ruin
your life just that right in this
today's environment it's trying to get a
job at Google they're like ah no and
then you're like but I was just you know
there's Troy like 13 but that's the
thing they're super young they're super
yes Google's on your god yeah but
[ __ ] a come on man Zoey's or did did
hurt who posted I thought people were
better than this especially my so-called
friend that's a football player for the
same school
who's Malik mammad he's black he's a
white guy he's the one who posted it and
he was like me obviously upset about it
yeah well can i stupid yeah sometimes
kids want to say something that's so
outrageous just because and they're like
let's say it sounds like you're not
allowed to say this but let's just say
not and you're do you're doing it could
not because you believe it but because
you're just you're saying something it's
like you'd never be allowed to say that
something this goes into what I'm saying
about suppression if you tell people not
to do something and it's super taboo if
they're gonna do it something here's my
rebuttal of that I think that's too easy
man out for all these white girls who
are on social media Instagram me as a
teenager I would have no media that's
right damn it be yeah so when you say oh
they're being dangerous and I'm just
because you're suppressed no no no no no
you're giving them an out there you
can't put on [ __ ] in see yeah you're
right no you can't do that see maybe
facet yeah I don't care if your pencil
you not to say it for sure my parents
will not sit I've never been with my
friend should we all drop the n-bomb
just my parents said oh no no I give him
out be right there [ __ ] more all
right the racist [ __ ] well isn't it the
same thing as going like this in a car
hey baby I want you're at you know that
I mean this is the same I get the same
please don't only effects for certain
things you just wouldn't do and you sir
sure as [ __ ] when you when you post that
on Instagram so you know I'm gonna be
hurting people right snapchat they're
their friends so-called friends put
reposted because they're pissed off at
them for doing it so they post it onto
their Instagram but it was initially on
snapchat so they thought they would get
away with it yeah well okay so so yeah
maybe
young girls doing something that's
forbidden and [ __ ] you know I don't
know it's a toughie because they're kids
yeah kids do see this stuff well but
that is stuff then there's racist 17 on
social media but do they even know like
so in other words racist like are they
saying that black people shouldn't be
allowed to vote what are they saying to
me that's like doing something forbidden
and bad and sometimes people get off on
doing forbidden bad things like that so
it's not necessarily racism right yes I
would say it so it's exactly I would say
it's a lot of things I would say people
do a lot of weird [ __ ] that's not
there's other surprising things you can
say that aren't racist though that you
could get a rise from people yeah a lot
of people wouldn't do this that's the
thing so I don't think any most people
would it happened again an old lady in
China threw coins in Holland
she should have saved this there was no
way to save this [ __ ] well you will
mention it again but yeah sure
don't bring it up save for one Tony save
it alright so here's something else in
China a random dude just pushed this
train attendant for no reason and I'll
show you the video psycho definitely
psycho so the train attendant on this
side one on this side so the one on this
side you see a older man kind of walking
towards her if my video stops freezing
so he starts walking towards her it's
not nothing happened he just pushes her
over and luckily there's no trains
coming there's no train they caught him
they arrested him what were they doing
before this were that were they like in
a dispute or something no never said
never yeah just some random girl just
did it and she injured her jaw no [ __ ]
oh just give that little forearm shiver
there Jesus man what's wrong with people
I don't know was it a guy from Hong Kong
doing that he has a Hong Kong ID but
he's not necessarily Chinese or anything
like that so well guy sucks alright have
you heard about a Navy SEAL that was on
Fox News there was actual segment about
this Navy SEAL and he made this
beautiful seal for president Trump he
said he was a not only was he a Navy
SEAL he served in Vietnam and he has two
Purple Hearts a recipient of two Purple
Hearts and it all turned out to be a lie
he made all of it up all of it up now
how stupid he's 72 how stupid you have
to be this day and age to lie that
you're in the Navy SEALs in all this
[ __ ] when all it's so easy to find
anything out these days I know he made a
seal a glass shield yeah apparently too
he he gave it to two presents before so
this guy has some sort of history with
presidents but awesome he lied about his
service
god-awful and Fox has to retract or they
actually retracted the story there are
few a service in Vietnam is missing in
action he said he was missing in action
twice two Purple Hearts
never served wait the interview they're
like uh he goes they go you're a hero he
goes no I'm not a hero
maybe with Eagles what was why why would
you
say that he was there heroes are the
ones that didn't come back that
something that they would say now that's
a liar ain't it oh I lie and that's a
lie
you said it kept building and building
though it was small wait well this is me
but this is me ready man sorry I'm late
why ask me why I'm late where are you a
[ __ ] part this is everyday I couldn't
find there was parking you know and I'm
lying that's a lie I lied his entire
life
whoa have you seen the the I forget it's
active I forget what the the it's a
count or a website where they find
people who they you know they make this
stuff up and they get approached by real
yeah in business so embarrassing
like the guy who's in a bar with Navy
SEALs pertains Navy SEAL they take her
outside dude admit to us you not need
feel like where did you do your chain I
think I do that and he says like that's
our real place
your [ __ ] light and there's like six
gnarly Navy SEALs you know I'm right go
street clothes I do no thanks
wow that guy that's the guy yeah it's
the one that does the yeah I've seen it
exposes them well she got that's that
guy serve at all does he have any
military past he was in the Navy for for
like three years or something okay whoa
wild boars terrorized Germantown and
injure for me a pain they severed
someone's finger too we got pictures let
me caught them on camera here there's
only it you don't see them do any you
know you see them going into an actual
store they injured at least four people
in there rampage and severed someone's
finger they don't look that mean sir
they are run into the store they don't
look that tough and then you see people
start coming off a delicious they make
my mouth water I'd shoot that oh [ __ ]
they're like chasers holy [ __ ] yeah I
think it's scared they probably tusked a
couple of people right look at this
thing he's trying to get out he's just
like get me the [ __ ] out of here what am
i hot to get in here and that's the
aftermath broken glass
probably there's blood well don't [ __ ]
around with borz apparently it's really
bad problem in Germany yeah well they
boys just on the loose they every Larkin
like wildfire in Texas I heard it's a
big problem
oh you just got like Tim Kelly you're
just down yes what you can't actually
they can't hunt their way out of the
problem there's got to be another way to
do it it's really hard and they go feral
at me apparently in like three weeks
they nice they're good meat delicious
meat bores sure it's like put some pork
right pork
I don't like pork yummy yum yum really
I'm a big pork boy ah you call me the
cowboy
I don't like pork I'm known as the pork
boy pork chop pork chop call me the pork
chop pork you chop another port day you
don't like sausages or bacon yeah I like
bacon I guess I would say I like other
than that no I don't like pork it on oh
no religious thing that's not like pork
mm-hmm I like swine not even swine
learning this wine this disgusting
animal
it's liking the pigeon 1g2 pigeon you
eat the pigeon pigs pigs pigs are pigeon
of the lamb eating squab yeah so pigeon
is squab pigeon is deliberate that many
times where in French restaurants and
stuff squash is a beautiful thing I will
need it oh no it's delicious
no you will eat it not death don't make
me mad cuz you will I don't like path
day we keep touching here man it's not
grown back dude you you wouldn't like a
pigeon and I don't eat pig
you're gonna eat [ __ ] squab what are
you talking about it's like it tastes
like pheasant it's a quail you're equal
to gave me for me come on bro you red
chicken you [ __ ] a chicken's a boar
now if you had duck you like yourself
that dog too greasy little too greasy
huh hmm all right I hate that [ __ ]
moose roast that Rogen gave me god damn
moose is good taste exactly like beef
but it's really good some dude who sent
us the the truffles down there I think
it's urban truffle sickness because we
robbed as a young domesticated chicken
well it's a chicken so hey under four
weeks old I was talking about a pigeon
pigeon I said domestic I meant pigeon so
what they're four weeks old so book is
that you never had pigeon that's
pitching scrub but don't you eat them in
there for under four weeks old I'm out
of New York
kids I get older I like nopt I'm out of
pigeon too cute New York
open them up eat them the ones that live
in the suit I'll try like this I'm
talking homeboy to New York pigeon
one of those you don't know if I was a
homeless guy beaten pigeon all [ __ ]
day do you not eat crow I see these
giant crows by my house you're smart too
smart
can't even they're too cool don't ever
eat a crow if I ever see you eating
cruddud if I ever [ __ ] it's like what
would you say Rosa octopus of the sky I
would say a crow is the [ __ ] dolphin
to the sky bro there are smartest awful
no socks are smarter than dolphins do
what you know you know I could sweat ah
you eat squid octopus octopus are smart
cats they're not smart stops Martin Katz
the research come out smart cat listen
me right now look at me oh listen up the
puss is a smart animal not as smart as
the dolphin and the shahbazi Ponzi they
think that that crows can be as smart as
she bones ease her crows are smartest
[ __ ] but octopus even smart smart very
smart you eat octopus III can you I
can't believe you're bringing this up
because I was [ __ ] [ __ ] about how they
can read your face if you're a scuba
diver they can tell whether or not your
mass is mean or yeah I read that three
years ago no not only that I just read
this other thing about how they also
really important for protecting the
reefs because they they are really top
predators I'm not eating octopus anymore
I decided yesterday right I decided you
have fur at the restaurant New York we
had that octopus really good oh my god
because that's restaurant revenue that
was so listen email please I used to
know the name of that [ __ ] restaurant
it's the best restaurant I've ever been
to numero uno I was talking [ __ ] about
New York food I'd say la food is better
in general it is but that restaurant is
the best restaurant of every met that
restaurant is called that restaurant is
called
c'mon Delphine de Feeney's Delphine II
by the way that's the company that sent
you the truffles Urbani truffle if the
[ __ ] just do those truffles so where
are they they're right here each box
I told my said Bremen to Brian yeah
doing anything with him I kept it in my
fridge over the weekend so I wouldn't
spoil nasty
there's a bunch you won't do it on there
there's a lunch there's a bunch of oil
and stuff in there too right there's
like a bunch I guess it's the jam and
butters different things in little tiny
glass jars so you can they send us a
real mushroom I think the boxes the one
that mg's bring it's here now that the
boxes have the truffles in it
so if you guys want to open them up
let's just open this stuff first of all
thank you to our Bonnie truck I would
just thank you just open this one I'm
doing one yeah just our Bonnie truffles
thank you see what there's anything I
kind of wrapped it a lot
well they wrapped in the bubble wrap all
kinds of different ruffled products just
a shitload of truffle oils and soils all
right take that Lindsey take that home
rub that all over your body
sure well don't tell me what to do but I
will shut up the truffle day that
restaurant was the best what else you
got
wait what was the name of that I mean
you said the best cookie you'd ever find
out the restaurant forget I post that on
there guys this might be a [ __ ] real
mushroom I'm gonna freak out if you said
he sent one yeah there should be real
truffles in there white truffle butter
oh it's truffle butter never mind that
smells like [ __ ] in there [ __ ] the
fennel [ __ ] that they're strong they're
strong smell you also shoot your pants
now for the faint of heart no let me
good though B take it home petition oh
whoa I don't know how much of a news
this is but Justin Bieber got a new
tattoo I saw a lot of great artwork if
you're just who did this buddy do it
some guy from Bruce Lee bang bang NYC
has like 1.5 million followers I've seen
way better work hello and I saw Mike I
expected better art work at it well
there's that B there's a cross there's a
skull there's a I don't give a [ __ ] what
Tom then I'm just saying like the
artworks not great I have seen that way
better art my friend agretti
I mean well these angels [ __ ] on him I'm
sure that artist is great maybe that's
what Beiber wanted yeah man I've
definitely seen better work done so
sugar is the Biebs you can't bribe
anyone the world and money's not an
issue you can see his old tattoo that's
like the shittiest cover-up look at you
can see the writing look at the skeleton
at the bottom it looks like Nightmare
Before Christmas now as a guy who gets
his whole body tattooed are you gonna
wake up in ten years ago this is a
[ __ ] annoying tattoo though because
it's not really about anything is it I
mean I don't know if it is but we don't
Barrett
fair to say we don't know the meaning
but there's a grizzly bear and a lion
and there's there's a lot of Gothic
imagery and then there's an eagle it's
hard to clown on some for tattoos you
don't know what it means to them you
know I'm saying especially you don't
have a tattoo and you're supposed to get
one well oh yeah remember that everyone
yeah I like keep warming that ups he's
got a badass angel there with big wings
maybe I'll get one of those I want to
get it I'm gonna get an a badass angel I
don't know if I'm as famous as the Biebs
I'm gonna Nick that dude you might
already have one come on Brian he has
this thing the area
maybe I'll get that at 50 I think I got
I'm just surprised man I've seen better
work a lot there's some amazing work out
there now when I sketch in I think
that's it boom
the beefs we finish on the beep stats
mm-hmm oh did you know that Donald Trump
deferred his enlistment what's something
called again when you're uh wouldn't
they make you go draft a draft yeah he
deferred it five times I didn't know
that oh well that's a tournament or
breaking news not just something I saw
in the news yeah she's releasing the JFK
tapes I heard they were gonna do it
anyways he's taking credit for it that's
what a surprise that what a Solon
character I can't you know that it was
due to release a bunch of it anyways and
now he's acting like he did it yeah it's
crazy huh did you guys see the video of
Max Kellerman wrapping that a fan sent
is that real you know all about is I
can't believe no notice 94 I don't want
new Mac tumors a rapper I don't know
really I don't know I mean maybe I'm
balls demon boy he's been a fan of Max
Kellerman but yeah he's a rapper Fred
you know his brother died by a boxer
yeah was murdered by boxer his brother
was a you know came out here was a rider
and was super super talented and was
living with a you know pretty big-time
upcoming boxer and the boxer murdered
him if that boxer had major problems too
he'd knocked somebody out after he lost
the guy came up and said good job and he
hit him really hard he had real problem
with you when murder like outside the
ring or the outside ring they were
roommates with their roommates and the
guy wanted he was like dude you owe me
rent where's my [ __ ] rent and then he
came in and murder
yeah yeah max Hillman was a crazy like
legit rapper well well I say legit like
he wasn't terrible
yeah like award-winning but you could
rap have you seen it
bring it up Jen yeah everyone always
tagged me I don't respond like yeah no
[ __ ] it's like when people attack me
like you know Brian was and Bubba
Sparxxx music videos hey everyone I'm
very aware been friends to Brian for a
very long time we've been over and
there's everything about me people when
they tag like yeah I don't respond to my
give a [ __ ] I cried Peter is going super
slow but I'll pull it up yeah pretty
weird Mexico knows rapper pre legit
don't take a break while you find this
he finds out you think this you found
the Mex Kellerman video junior it is
[Music]
anyways actually good it's funny huh
he's not bad at all
I don't know rap well but it sounds a
little bit like Eminem all right what do
you gotta be got all dropping knowledge
at starters interesting um talk about
white rappers well human beings are
truly taking over the planet as we say I
just heard these interesting statistics
in in millions of tons how many if you
took all the human beings on a planet
and put them on a scale how much either
they weigh and they've got pretty
accurate assessments of this and tons
yeah I have no idea I haven't 300
million tons it's a lot of time a lot of
times right cuz our 2,000 pounds to a
ton so that's a 300 million tons right
so that would be what six hundred
million we talk about tons though you
know it's kind of a lot of tons it's
happy it's a lot of times people are
happy people are having everyone in the
world 300 million times 2,000 so we can
figure out how many pounds that is how
many domesticated animals do you think
they'd be more of tons again like yeah
more or less more more about how much a
shitload of animal how much domesticated
like cows sheeps only domesticated yeah
nice domesticated you fuk moot what
twice have a job 700 million not bad
what were you gonna say how many pounds
six hundred billion pounds large wild
animals makeup if you took all the what
large wild animals from porcupines too
[ __ ] yeah this is so fast honest time
before gear I'm like you what's pissing
me off faintly
how many how many turns to all the
[ __ ] cows were in the world if I
don't find out I'm gonna bust how many
really be pissed
actually though it's interesting that
this metric yeah I think about all the
times to my face well I'm Caitlyn's kids
are clones coz turn really [ __ ] cross
my day
well okay both pounds pounds I meant
pounds but I just think is interesting
because there are there are 80,000
drafts for example rough yeah in the
wild compared to 1.5 bill
in cattle there are about 250,000 wolves
in the wild that's pretty is that a lot
or no no it's not right now and 400
million dogs and then they're about I
believe 250,000 she ballsy's and then
returned thousands one white run and
there are seven billion is one white one
white rhino and the biggest threat is
not that animals cuz you go as breed
animals in captivity in fact they're
having they have a breeding why yeah
they got a breeding program for rhino
rhinoceroses so that they can flood the
market with the horns and horns won't be
as expensive because what as long as
horns on rhinos are gonna fetch you so
there that's a killer they're gonna bet
you like you know what let's call it a
hundred two hundred three that hunt down
those crime syndicates gonna find ways
to get that [ __ ] horn at night okay
with infrared stuff you're not gonna
like legalizing drugs in the US correct
and the Mexican cartels go off vodka
yeah that's right go figure something
that's right that's right that's how I
look at so they're doing these breeding
programs cuz that's the only way but the
biggest threat to our environment is
continual habitat so that you because
animals need to migrate you need
migratory patterns so as you have
development and it stops those migratory
patterns you can't just have parks
because it changes the entire ecosystem
they don't behave the same way isn't
that [ __ ] weird anyway really really
is the worst job knowledge yet beyond
prepared very unprepared no I was
prepared I have another one plants I'm
good hey uh canteen to us
I just noticed them yeah you better be
careful I want you to be careful because
I know why it has to be careful but
these are I'm not saying this coming
don't like good jeans
I bought him oh really I went into a
store and I bought them now in Calgary
yeah now hold on tight all the oil
workers give them to you excuse me these
are these are sort of dungarees but
they're gray then they go well with
certainly both no you when I stand as
though you have a crate on my rump
you rub never looks better in jeans no I
think shown podcast we started with you
dreaming of [ __ ] dudes
oh I just asked never looks better Jean
can you have lunch after this you have
to go do something no I'm good man
you can heat yeah I'm talking about
right I know well since we spent some
time to about tons you know what let's
go to lunch talk about tons talk about
Canada talk about lots of other stuff oh
my dates and Moffat my dates my James
miss out you and I are going to Vegas
this weekend that's gonna be fun yeah
whether I though yeah I know we'll have
some fun and then I'm gonna be at the
Gotham comedy club which I haven't told
anybody about November 17th and 18th in
New York City
well the great clubs in the world right
Gotham comedy club and then guess what
that's a low place called New York City
money yeah New York City the Gotham
comedy club November 17 18 if you
remember the last time I was there what
happened it's a bomb remember to call me
club yes
well see all right well sure was cut
short no last night doesn't call me Club
much people got murdered I was on stage
no but I remember that yeah it does
first time I saw you do an hour does
that might that's my second time right
show Gotham coming clobb special place
my heart it's the 17th and 18th last
time I was there I was on stage Saturday
nights so excited and they came right up
on stage and took the mic out of my hand
said we gotta get out of here we gotta
get you out of here Jimmy Burke yep it
was a terrorist act but I will be there
this November 17th 18th then I will be
it in Utah in Salt Lake City wise guys
you know wise guys you've done wise guys
wise guys getting all the girls club
banks yep Thanksgiving weekend oh why
why why it's white why it's everywhere
White's everywhere papayas White's
everywhere yeah yeah so Utah wiseguys
and then and then cobs December 7th 8th
9th I'm at cops comedy club in San
Francisco no factory calm for all bryan
callen
tickets and my dates then i am and it's
coming up man
what shit's real soon November 3rd i'ma
Colusa casino that [ __ ] is almost sold
out Colusa casino that's northern cow
I'm at the comedy zone in Charlotte that
is November
ix then I go from Charlotte to Zanies in
Nashua a nice for two nights the 10th
11th of November Zane East Nashville and
then that Sunday I'm in Columbus Ohio
for the first time funny bone that is
November 12 Inland Empire on the 30th
Ontario improv and then just announced
and they just went on sale Buffalo New
York
December 14th through 16th my first full
weekend Buffalo New York be I'm excited
for you New York City tell me how that
it's cuz I December 14th through 16th
evacuate calm for tickets right now and
a little birdie just told me my tickets
in Denver went on sale Comedy Works what
one night only wrong Denver baby don't
walk T fat cake on for Brian and myself
this is a finer kid we're out